hello and welcome to part 4 of my SEO
tutorial here we're going to be
discussing URLs in the structure and all
that one of the most common questions is
typically should I use dashes or
underscores in my URL I see this all the
time and if you you know like type this
into google you would get kind of
conflicting and varying opinions and a
lot of people will tell you that it
really doesn't matter or something like
that or that you could just straight up
just type all the words without either
of those things and Google's still
recognize it boy if you just if you look
down google.com / webmasters they
actually will explicitly tell you that
you should use hyphens or dashes instead
of underscores and everything else so
that solves that question right out of
the gate hyphens and dashes now on that
same pages they're talking about hyphens
and dashes they're also telling you
about URL structuring and a good example
this is like dynamic URLs and websites
use these typically to track users on
their sites without using tracking
cookies and so like a good example of
this would be like a shopping site to
track user activity so they can figure
out what's the likelihood or how can we
better get someone to hurry up and make
a purchase and then really all kinds of
analytics really so like if you go to
like amazon or newegg i think does it
too i'm sure a lot of them do it and you
look at a product a lot of times like
underneath that product it says hey what
ninety percent of people did when they
like view this page or what fifty
percent of the people actually purchased
after looking at this you know that's
all from you know they just track what
everybody's doing and they can do all
kinds of cool analytics on that so
that's really cool but the way that's
done is it's they give you these it's
kind of like a session ID but not really
gives a bunch of ids about where you
where where you've come from basically
and this kind of just results in a
really highly cryptical URL and urls are
going to lead to identical content so if
you recall when we just recently made
those sitemaps remember how many URLs
that were like
my website we have I think in total
there was like 300 something URLs now
imagine if you had a special code or a
special URL for every single path
combination of those links like I had
right that would result in a huge number
of URLs for Google have to go through I
mean hundreds and hundreds of thousands
if not millions if you depending on how
many pads you really had so obviously
that's not good because they can kind of
clogged up Google increase the amount of
time that it's going to take for it just
to crawl your site if at all how often
it's going to be crawled and in the end
it's going to impact your website's
presence on Google period so other
things too like session IDs like I was
kind of saying search results things
like calendars all that stuff can be
really problematic because they have
almost like an infinite number of
possibilities especially like a calendar
so that's just that's obviously no bueno
so now at the same time you have to
understand that dynamic URLs are also
really really helpful and besides just
shopping wise they can help to create a
very unique and good customer or user
experience so what gives man I thought
you said that was the whole point of
this stuff right well that's right but
we do also need to remember that that
the other portion of SEO is to
accommodate google so you can do this
but it's just going to take a little bit
longer so what can we do to actually
accommodate Google well luckily there is
a way to have your cake and eat it too
so what you can do is tell Google not to
crawl specific links now you might be
like well that's you just said that it
would add like hundreds of thousands of
lanes and so that's no good you wouldn't
want to have to do all that by hand
either but what you can do is use
regular expressions and to denote a
whole plethora of links now I imagine
probably a lot of you looking into this
our program is your cell so you might
actually have you know familiarity with
regular expressions but a lot of people
still hate them anyways and but i will
show you guys exactly how to edit your
robots.txt file with these regular
expressions and don't worry it's really
not truly regular expressions it's like
one
regular expressions it's not a big deal
but i will show you guys anyways but
before we end this video and continue in
the next video with the editing of that
robots.txt file a couple more points i
just want to make real quick on urls is
one you want to keep the URL length
short so and you want to try to have it
be as relevant to the page as possible
right that it you know whatever is on
that page you kind of want it to be
close and the other thing you should do
periodically is check for broken urls so
that's like urls there in a wind of
leading to content that no longer exists
on your website or maybe it exists but
you've changed the path or the directory
of that content so it just it still
breaks right and this is actually really
common to a curry you just don't realize
that as you do stuff to your website and
not only does it stop google from you
know indexing if you just can't go any
further but it's also going to disrupt
your users and no doubt results in a
very high rate of exit from that point
so obviously not a good idea so like
with wordpress for example you can
choose exactly how you put out your
links but i think by default like their
links are like if you like make a post
it's like post love about so look like
that that's no good you kind of want it
to be somewhat like what you're talking
about so like a year as a post right
here what can blackbird you different
and my link is the date and then the
title with dashes or hyphens or if you
want to call them so it's got you know
so it's a very it's a fairly short URL
obviously it's the whole title here but
it's fairly short and you can decide
whether or not you want a date there
that's just kind of like up to you i
suppose so anyway that's like that or
you could be like 4x item in here and
it's just sent text with 4x and that is
what this page is all about right so
very short succinct URL so anyway those
are just some basics on urls and dynamic
urls especially in the next video we
will be talking about the how to edit
that robot text file so google doesn't
actually try to go into the infinity and
beyond with all kinds of dynamic URL so
that's what we'll be talking about the
next video as always thanks for watching
thanks for your support your
subscriptions and some
so